c'est à Madame Maud petit pour le groupe
démocrate
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé le 17 octobre
dernier se tenait la Journée mondiale de
contre la douleur je veux rappeler ici
qu'il y a des mots invisibles et
quotidiens qui détruisent des vies je
souhaite porter aujourd'hui la voix de
ceux qui subissent les affres des
douleurs chroniques et leur dire qu'ils
ne sont pas seuls que leur combat et le
nôtre les causes de la douleur chronique
sont multiples suite d'une opération
chirurgicale d'un traitement médical et
fait d'une maladie en résulte une
souffrance quotidienne invalidante
parfois silencieuse souvent la douleur
chronique concerne près de 12 millions
de nos compatriotes 20% de notre
population elle touche n'importe lequel
d'entre nous à tous les âges source de
handicap d'isolement social de
souffrance psychologique mais aussi
d'inactivité d'absentéisme professionnel
il en résulte un phénomène sociétal en
augmentation à prendre en compte la loi
du 4 mars 2002 relative au droit des
malades et à la qualité du le système de
santé reconnaît la prise en charge et le
soulagement de la douleur comme des
droits fondamentaux du patient je vous
interroge ainsi sur la pérennisation des
structures douleurs chroniques qui
prennent en charge des patients
douloureux complexes sur le territoire
métropolitain et ultramarins ce
dispositif unique en Europe constitue un
maillon essentiel du parcours de soins
et participe à la diminution de
l'errance diagnostic et thérapeutiques
après trois plans nationaux de lutte
contre la douleur cependant le modèle
s'essouffle la couverture territoriale
est hétérogène et fragile les nombreux
départs à la retraite non remplacé
l'offre actuelle couvre seulement 1,4%
des patients elle ne couvre pas les
besoins des patients douloureux les plus
complexes les sociétés savantes sont
dans l'attente de la publication par la
HAS des recommandations relatives au
parcours des soins du patient douloureux
elles appellent à plusieurs mesures pour
pérenniser et démultiplier ce modèle de
prise en charge monsieur le ministre
quel est donc la feuille de route du
gouvernement pour pérenniser ses Stru et
assurer un accès effectif à une prise en
charge de qualité des patients
douloureux dans notre pays je vous
remercie beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur François Braun
ministre de